Train Ride.
Choo Choo! All aboard!
It's time for a fantastic train ride.
Our train is taking a magic trip through the Rocky Mountains.
Look at the scenery.
Wow! Look at those big mountains.
Look at the green forest.
What else do you see?
You can sit on the top floor of the train or on the bottom.
You can even sleep on this train and order food to eat.
There are not many trains in Canada.
This train is called the Rocky Mountaineer.
It does not go fast like a bullet train.
It goes slower so that people can look at the beautiful scenes outside.
This is a special train, and it's very popular with tourists.
A train ride is a good way to see the Rocky Mountains.